[Musique]
on a un chien qu'est ce qui te prends tu
es malade ça va tu maîtrises pas d'
accès de colère incontrôlable jette une
colère normal et légitime tu reprends
bien l'aspect de jane pendant son
sommeil c'était indispensable la corne
de brume désolé j'ai pas pu résister il
va te falloir plusieurs années pour
apprendre à maîtriser tout ce que ça
implique
elias way qui est ton meilleur ami
unique
l'élasthanne c'est l'élasthanne ton
meilleur ami être un hulk exige un
certain sens de l'équilibré
tu as encore tellement à apprendre
ouais
bon tu vois bien que j'ai réussi tous
les tests
écoute si tu veux retourner à david
avocate je respecte ton choix il ne
pense pas
[Musique]
de plus en plus de super humain
apparaissent un peu partout
nous avons créé un service spécialement
pour eux et je veux que miss hulk en
soit la représentante
namasté
j'ai un sérieux conflit d'intérêts cet
homme a tenté de tuer mon cousin brousse
oui je connais la faire
les gens s'intéressent à moi uniquement
parce que je représente emil blonsky il
s'intéresse vraiment à toi parce qu'ils
disent
les faits montrent que c'est pas vrai je
l'aimé tellement spyer
[Musique]
j'en suis pas très fier
mademoiselle walter ce nous répondons un
plus grand pouvoir notre univers est au
bord du précipice
je suis avocate
je dois me conformer au livre pour livre
des méchants petit nom au livre de droit
américain à la loi quoi
que ça te plaise ou non tu es désormais
une super héroïne c'est quand vous
voulez
vous vous souvenez de la copine que vous
aviez au lycée
celle qui était bien plus cool que vous
super canon et celle qui attirait tous
les regards
quand je suis jalouse c'est ça que
ressemble la jalousie
[Musique]